[Applaudissements]
bonjour à toutes et à tous merci à
christian jacob notre président merci à
pierre bédier nous accueillir dans ce
très beau département et merci à valérie
pécresse
notre présidente de région que nous
soyons d'île de france ou pas de ces
mots d'accueil et de ces mots de
rassemblement à mon tour de vous
souhaiter la bienvenue de vous remercier
pour votre présence tout au long de ces
deux journées vous allez être plus en
plus nombreux à nous rejoindre pour que
ce rendez vous de la jeunesse prenne
tout son sens et dès à présent christian
jacob vous l'a annoncé tout à l'heure
nous allons passer au coeur de ces deux
journées c'est à dire la réflexion le
débat d'idées les échanges avec les uns
et les autres et si vous étiez venu pour
entendre une litanie de discours vous
serez déçu en revanche si vous êtes
venus pour participer au débat pour
apporter vos contributions pour être la
locomotive de notre famille politique
alors vous êtes au bon endroit ce rendez
vous de la jeunesse durant ces deux
journées il vous donne la parole
c'est à vous chacune et chacun d'entre
vous quelles que soient vos convictions
quelles que soient vos nuance quelles
que soient vos parcours vos histoires
c'est à vous que reviendra le fait de
faire vivre nos idées sur les grands
sujets que nous avons décidé de mettre à
l'ordre du jour des ateliers
d'aujourd'hui et des tables rondes aux
plénières de la journée de demain
quelques mots d'organisation pratique
dans quelques minutes vont s'ouvrir
quatre ateliers qui déboucheront demain
sur des tables rondes aux plénières ces
ateliers vont se dérouler dans plusieurs
salles que je vais vous indiquez sur ce
site du port marly
je vous invite à vous y répartir les uns
les autres je vous invite aussi à vous
mettre un peu en danger
on accepte nous se mettre en danger en
vous faisant venir en vous en participer
au débat il faut que vous aussi vous
n'alliez pas nécessairement vers les
ateliers qui vous intéresse a priori
tous les sujets sont importants et vous
apprendrez sûrement beaucoup plus vous
amènerait beaucoup plus sur les ateliers
qui vous paraissent pas instinctif pour
vous mais qui sont tout aussi
essentielle que ceux auxquels vous
auriez pensé initialement
quatre ateliers donc qui vont s'ouvrir
avec à chaque fois des animateurs et les
animatrices dont je vais vous donner des
noms ils seront chargés de répartir la
parole de vous faire intervenir
je le redis la parole elle est à chaque
fois pour chacun de ces ateliers à la
salle c'est la salle qui intervient
selon une règle simple deux minutes de
prise de parole deux minutes de réponse
il ya des compteurs les intervenants
seront là pour les respecter parce que
je le redis c'est vous qui allez prendre
la parole et être les locomotives
aujourd'hui quatre ateliers qui demain
déboucheront sur des tables rondes
plénière vous aurez donc l'occasion
d'assister à tous les débats lors de la
journée de demain et ses ateliers vont
nous permettent d'alimenter les journées
et les travaux que nous aurons samedi
vous l'avez compris nous sommes là pour
travailler s'agit pas d'une seule
festivités il s'agit véritablement de
vous permettre de contribuer je vous
rappelle les gestes barrière qui sont
essentiels le port du masque lorsque
vous serez dans les salles nous avons à
faire en sorte d'avoir des chaises
suffisamment distancié les uns des
autres
présentez vous lorsque vous prenez la
parole lavez vous les mains les mains
aussi souvent que possible et si vous
avez besoin de vous embrasser les uns
des autres
cachez vous vous faites le plus tard
pour le reste et les choses plus
sérieuses quatre ateliers qui vont donc
débuter le premier sur la conciliation
de cette grande et belle idée de la
république et des réussites au pluriel
c'est constance de pjcci maire de la
ferté saint aubin et secrétaire générale
adjointe des républicains qui va animer
cette table ronde
elle aura autour d'elle daniel fasquelle
récent mère est heureux mère du tout qui
est trésorier des républicains michel
vial et député des yvelines
ronan le gleut sénateurs et secrétaire
général adjoint et guillaume guérin
président de limoges métropole lui aussi
secrétaire général adjoint pour cette
table ronde cet atelier comme pour
chacun des ateliers un responsable
départemental des jeunes qui sera chargé
de faire le rapporteur de ce qui sera
dit nous en parlera tout à l'heure lors
du compte-rendu autour d'annie genevard
et et de guillaume pelletier et qui
demain ouvrira les tables rondes avec
nos intervenants politiques et c'est
donc vincent emballante est rouffiac
le responsable départemental des jeunes
de la fédération de paris qui sera
chargée de l'animateur première table
ronde république et réussite et ça se
passe dans la salle verrière je vous
invite dès la fin de mon propos à sortir
de l'amphithéâtre et vous aurez une
signalétique qui vous aiment d'accra la
bonne salle une deuxième un deuxième
atelier réconcilier europe et et
souveraineté
christian jacob l'a évoqué dans son
introduction c'est dans la salle
marquise que ça se passera cette année
c'est vrai même député européen et vice
présidente de la région
ile de france qui sera chargé de
l'animation elle aura pour difficile
tâche d'encadrer des personnalités pas
les moindres par les plus disciplinées
pas les plus simples encadré mais parce
qu'elles ont des choses à dire
nadine morano député européen olivier
marc l'ex député d'eure-et-loir et eric
woerth député de l'oise et président de
la commission des finances à l'assemblée
nationale
le troisième atelier réconcilier
écologie et croissance interne est
essentielle
c'est sophie gaugain vice-président de
la région normandie qui animera cette
table ronde elle est aussi secrétaire
général adjoint des républicains elle
aura autour des leurs à fashion berger
député du haut rhin est ce que tu es en
général adjoint julien dive député de
l'aisne et alexandre vincent deh maire
de rillieux la pape qui va nous
rejoindre c'est geoffroy backs de
kenting responsable départemental des
jeunes des yvelines qui sera chargé de
faire le rapport enfin la dernière le
dernier atelier démocratie et autorités
de l'état concilier démocratie autorités
de l'état c'est gilles platret maire de
chalon sur saône et vice président des
républicains qui sera chargé de
l'animation il aura autour de lui jean
françois copé maire de meaux
frédéric péchenard vice président de la
région ile de france est et conseiller
de paris philippe juvin maire de la
garenne colombes et et chef des urgences
de l'hôpital georges pompidou et c'est
marie glinel responsable départementale
adjointe du département de la haute
garonne qui sera chargé du rapport et
cet atelier se passera dans cette même
salle ici l'amphithéâtre
voilà ce que j'avais pour ma part à vous
dire on compte sur votre discipline en
ce sens que dès que mon propos est
terminée on vous invite un bonne part à
sortir de cette salle pour vous répartir
dans les autres ateliers et pour ceux
qui restent sur l'atelier démocratie
autorités à rester dans cette salle à 17
heures un gong retentira dans l'ensemble
des salles ce sera donc la fin des
ateliers ou un peu plus tard 17h30
contenu de l'avant ce que nous avons
prises et l'ensemble des participants se
retrouveront ici pour les comptes rendus
autour de la présidente du conseil
national et du vice président délégué de
notre mouvement
bon après midi de travail à chacune et
chacun d'entre vous